il n'y aura pas de parade pour la
victoire de l'armée ukrainienne à Liman
ce qui défile ce sont des maisons
brûlées éventrées des édifices
gouvernementaux ravagés le prix de
l'occupation dont on voit encore les
traces buriner sur les petits commerces
et kiosque par les occupants russes que
l'iman paiera longtemps la Russie règne
peut-on lire sur le passage de ses
soldats Ukrainiens qui ont libéré la
ville il y a quelques jours plus
maintenant seule quelques habitants
déambules d'un palour qui trahit les tas
de choc dans lequel il se trouve et
rappelle que la ville n'est pas tout à
fait fantôme le choc n'efface pas la
colère exprimée au hasard des rencontres
ils ne veulent pas parler que
pourrait-on dire de toute façon
il y a trop à faire pour se préparer à
l'hiver qui s'installera trop vite avant
que tout ce qui a été détruit ne soit
reconstruit que les fenêtres éclatées ne
soient remplacées que le gaz ne puisse
offrir de quoi se chauffer
l'hôpital ne sert plus à personne ici
aussi bien lui prendre un peu de bois
pour se faire un feu
lou Bove souligne que son prénom veut
dire amour il en faudrait beaucoup plus
aux hommes dit-elle facile nous avions
très peur ce n'est pas que l'on a
supporté l'occupation dit-elle mais on
savait que personne ne pouvait l'arrêter
je ne sais pas ce qui va arriver
maintenant mais pourquoi c'est arrivé
c'est sa foi inébranlable qui lui permet
de tenir aujourd'hui mais elle ne
comprend pas ses semblables
les enfants pleuraient ils avaient peur
et les animaux ils ne pouvaient rien
comprendre ils avaient faim ils ont
souffert à cause de nous nous sommes
pourtant intelligents nous devrions
comprendre les conséquences de nos
gestes mais il n'y a aucune pénitence
déplore le bof
l'imam est une victoire stratégique
importante pour l'Ukraine et hautement
symbolique pour Vladimir Poutine la
défaite ici est humiliante
la semaine dernière à peine il annexé la
ville après des référendums menés à la
pointe du fusil et déclarait l'imam
situé dans la région de Daniels et trois
autres régions d'Ukraine russe à tout
jamais
selon l'armée ukrainienne jusqu'à 5000
soldats
on ne sait pas combien ont été fait
prisonniers combien ont fui et combien
sont morts pour seul compte-rendu le
ministère de la défense de l'Ukraine a
déclaré que la majorité avait été
redéployée dans des sacs mortuaires ou
en captivité
les armes et les munitions qu'ils ont
laissé derrière en battant retraite sont
maintenant entre les mains de leurs
adversaires Ukrainiens qui ont bien
l'intention de les retourner contre eux
ici des ogives de la poudre explosive
des lance-roquettes
les Russes nous fournissent plus d'armes
que l'Union européenne nous lance
euphorique le commandant qui nous montre
son butin de guerre mais ne veut pas
être identifié
avec les amants c'est récentes qui se
multiplient il paraissent galvanisé les
soldats Ukrainiens au sud du pays et ici
dans l'Est en avant toute pour reprendre
la Russie un autre village et un autre
vite avant l'hiver et les risques
d'enlisement qu'il comportent
l'exaltation se lit sur ses visages que
nous ne pouvons révéler mais elle ne
masquent pas la fatigue l'amertume la
douleur des derniers mois la haine de
l'ennemi aussi
vous ne couperiez pas le bras de celui
qui fait mal à vos enfants à votre mari
ou à votre fils demande ce soldat que
feriez-vous nous leur rendant l'appareil
nous n'allons pas les capturer mieux
vaut les tuer sur place ils ont fait
beaucoup de mal et ça suffit
mais eux ne pensent qu'à ceux qui n'ont
pas survécu à la dernière bataille
plusieurs de nos âmes sont morts il n'y
avait plus que mon commandant et moi
raconte celui-là ces bâtards nous ont
tirés dessus vous devez le voir pour
comprendre je ne peux pas trouver les
mots d'écrire
il souffle un peu avant de poursuivre
plus à l'est c'est la seule route qui
permet pour l'instant un accès
relativement sécuritaire à la ville de
Liman la goutte elle-même a été dominée
mais les boisés de part et d'autre
contiennent encore énormément d'engins
explosifs de mines et de guet-apens
les mines et antichard sont dissimulés
dans les boisés
malgré que seuls les soldats russes tués
si demeure les équipes de déminage en
ont pour des jours avant de désamorcer
les plus évidentes
[Applaudissements]
il faudra des mois avant de pouvoir
éliminer tous les risques voici ce qui
reste de ceux qui ont tenté d'emprunter
cette route dans des voitures civiles
pour rejoindre Liman avec l'avancée de
l'armée ukrainienne des uniformes
discarter des rations des trousses
médicales quelques grenades tout doit
être vérifié avant d'être retiré de la
route
dans les villages qui mènent à Liman la
guerre n'avait pas attendu février
dernier pour commencer depuis 2014 les
villageois ont vu tantôt les combattants
séparatistes prorus débarqués tantôt les
soldats Ukrainiens tour à tour encore et
encore
ce cratère témoigne du dernier passage
dévastateur de l'armée russe ici celui
du retour par la force des Ukrainiens
plus rien ne tient sauf cette petite
maison dont l'entretien des tonnes parmi
la dévastation
un vieil homme y habite c'est noté sur
sa porte il a tout vécu tout vu tout
noté méticuleusement mais n'allez pas
lui demander de raconter pas maintenant
revenez plus tard
pour le moment il attend de voir si lui
et sa ménagerie vont survivre aux
prochain épisode violent Vladimir
Poutine a décidé qu'il était russe
maintenant ses soldats il en est
convaincu vont une fois de plus criblés
les fenêtres de sa maison de leur balle
ici marie-eveda Radio-Canada l'imam